villain how critical is hydroelectric to
California are they going to turn off
the night lights on the Hollywood sign
probably not just yet historically it's
been a huge part of that energy mix over
the last few years there's been
averaging around fifteen to eighteen
percent this year that may be down by
half we were up at one of the dams one
of the big reservoirs near Sacramento
yesterday called the Folsom dam and all
the levels there right now aren't too
terrible over the next few months as
they let water out to generate power
it's not going to be filled in with
snowmelt there's been so little snow up
in the Sierra that there's very very
little coming down there and actually
what that means is that some of the
operators some of the officials there
are going to be having juggle their
needs and so I sat down with the guy
that runs the the power grid for the
world's eighth-largest economy and I
asked him about the impact of the
drought on the electricity marketer
here's what he had to say hydro has
always been an important part of the mix
and it continues to be the drought
causes derating what we call derating
and availability of hydro but
interestingly enough the solar has
expanded so significantly in the last
few years that it largely offsets at
least for system-wide capacity are
drought impact on the hydro here's the
thing Olivia even if solar can make up
overall capacity when they lose hydro it
does have drawbacks one of them he told
me is flexibility hydro can release
electricity anytime the day or night
just by letting water out of the
reservoir it can generate it when it's
needed solar because the storage is so
expensive can only produce electricity
during daylight hours when the sun's out
and is shining so that means that those
are times where they may not be peak
demand but that's anytime the soda can
deliver the other drawback of course
across California is in certain local
municipalities they're very reliant on
hydro they are going to see energy costs
going up dramatically yeah of course I
guess ma sent I didn't think about it
but obviously a solar is a lot more
fickle because of the weather who's
going to be impacted here who are the
main energy players well you're looking
at some of the utilities they're going
to see their costs rise luckily for them
gas prices are quite low so they're able
to replace some of this with with you
know burning their gas and then when you
look at some of these smaller towns
these municipalities it's very
complicated with nexus between water and
energy there in California they're going
to see a huge impact obviously the
farmers are going to be spending
more money on their water also on their
energy and then you look at some of the
small hydro operators we've been talking
them all of this week these are guys who
sell the power to the grid up in the
mountains they spend a few million
dollars right now their revenues have
really down dramatically they're going
to be suffering the most what's your
impression from your week or so of
traveling throughout the state how
severe is the drought it's pretty bad
and I think you know I spoke to the one
of the chief hydrologist yesterday for
the Bureau of Reclamation they run some
of the largest reservoirs there he said
that this essentially is outside of
their models the last serious drought in
1977 was the worst date point they have
this is now forcing them to reconsider
how they're going to plan in the future
so a lot of shaming of almond milk
drinkers going on there has been some of
that and a little you know almond farm
is fighting back saying we get a lot of
bankrupt but we may require a lot of
water but we create a huge amount of
value for our colleague Joey Wiesenthal
tried to make house tour attention yeah
yeah yeah I don't know if I picked up
but I didn't prove very popular among I
don't feel a little bit more guilty
every time I put come and look at my
coffee vilemarcs thank you so much very
interesting there on the impact of the
drought on the hydroelectric situation
in California thank you